wenn der inspiration of the week geht es
um einen jungen mann der auf social
media über seine behinderung spricht
[Musik]
aufgrund eines sauerstoffmangels während
der schwangerschaft kam der 22 jährige
ricardo mit einer haltungs und
bewegungsstörungen zur welt in der
highschool versuchte der italiener sein
handicap zu verbergen weil er sich damit
schwach fühlte 2014 finger an aus seinem
zustand das bestmögliche herauszuholen
und dokumentierte seine g störung auf
social media der öffentlichkeit wird er
seitdem erkannt und angesprochen musiker
verteilte sogar ein video des italieners
anlässlich seines neuen songs
darin zu sehen ist ricardo wie er es
schafft mittlerweile ein paar schritte
alleine zu gehen sein rekord liegt bei
360 schritten
außerdem arbeitet er als designer für
sein eigenes modelabel und schrieb 2009
10 das buch genre happiness sein motto
ist macht eine schwäche zu deiner stärke
[Musik]